we heard earlier in the program about
how the national trust and other big
landowners have signed a pact to restore
wildlife habitats and cut carbon
emissions now the groups represent
around a third of english land so is
this something that farmers can get
behind and how does the idea of
improving biodiversity fit in with
industrial level agriculture so clearly
a question for you first of all and
about 70 of land in england is
agricultural isn't it so is this
something you think that farmers can get
behind
well i think it's something that farmers
have already been behind actually when i
go back to our 2014 net zero aspiration
for agriculture uh three four years ago
now we started that i worry sometimes
that that we become one dimensional so
actually we look at
biodiversity or we look at water quality
or we look at uh
carbon and then we'll sort of add food
into it as well for me what farmers need
to do going forward is deliver all of
those things produce fantastic foods but
also deliver on biodiversity carbon and
everything else we expected
if you're trying to make a profit and
you've got to give over a load of your
land to biodiversity
so the key for me is about actually lots
of these areas there's a sweet spot
where by using our resources more
efficiently by thinking about how we use
our land and which bits of land we use
we can absolutely deliver on food on the
environment on biodiversity where i
worry is actually this sort of wholesale
we'll just turn it all over the nature
we'll import our food from somewhere
else in the world and actually just
export our environmental footprint
british farmers want to do both those
things and i think is is really exciting
for the future laura how important are
these nature-based solutions and do you
feel that farmers are doing enough
i think farmers are doing a lot and you
can see that through the various
different initiatives that they have you
know i'm from scotland and it's really
fun going all over the country and
seeing the different solutions that
farmers have i think one of the
important things that we need to do is
also support them support them in both
the education and in the finance for
doing some of these solutions because
they are the custodians of lots of the
land that we have here in the uk and we
need to be supporting them because we
are also their customers and we really
want to buy food that is being
sustainably made and so we can all be
playing our part alongside them to help
deliver these nature-based solutions for
the land that we call home here in the
uk uh very briefly do you sometimes feel
like you're painted as the bad guys you
know agriculture responsible for lots of
methane emissions very briefly does that
feel like it do you look
too often agriculture seems the problem
whereas i see it as absolutely part of
the solution to biodiversity to carbon
but also to producing fantastic food in
a fantastic landscape okay stuart
roberts laura young really good to talk
to you both thanks very much for joining
us this evening